tonight on Brian Ross investigates he
leads a church with five million members
saying he is the apostle of Jesus Christ
but California prosecutors say this holy
man is a sick demented sex fiend
targeting teenage girls in his flock the
type of crimes that belong nowhere in
our society from human trafficking
production of child pornography oral
copulation rape now his church's plans
to build a city sized compound in rural
Georgia of local residents up in arms I
would say that they share more in line
with what people traditionally think of
as a cult will hear from the minister
defending the apostle and the church
what's happening in Georgia is a is a
war as a battle plus the decorated US
Navy SEAL now charged with war crimes in
Iraq Eddie Gallagher set to go to trial
next week as President Trump says he may
issue a presidential pardon his family
and lawyers speak out it's a very
emotional thing for us to have to go
through this level of shame and this
type of a travesty and our shout out for
the American journalist James Foley
killed by Isis five years ago and the
artist in Brooklyn who is now making it
his mission to let the world see the
amazing work Jim Foley left behind it is
a responsibility it's a responsibility
to create work that both honors and and
takes the next step beyond
simply being a memorial but one that
transforms and makes us think in a much
broader sense from the law and crime
Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates and good evening and
welcome tonight allegations of sexual
depravity and assault against teenage
girls by the leader of a fast growing
fundamentalist religious sect claiming 5
million members worldwide with 1 million
in the United States in all 50 states
the church leader claims to be the
apostle of God and authorities say he
told the teenage girls he allegedly
abused that by refusing him they would
be going against God
[Music]
the church calls itself the light of the
world claiming members in 58 countries
its leader is 50 year old nasaan joaquin
garcia who began his career as a
minister in Arizona and Southern
California
he teaches that he is the apostle of
Jesus Christ just like his father and
grandfather who founded the church
videos posted by the church show his
devoted followers treating joaquin
garcia like a holy figure his
charismatic appeal has helped the church
spread from its roots in Mexico
across the United States and beyond but
behind that all California authorities
say there is a dark side a cult of
personality used by joaquin garcia to
take advantage of some of his youngest
followers on monday night my office
arrested na song joaquin garcia
California Attorney General Xavier
Becerra says joaquin garcia and three of
his church leaders are charged in what
he called a major sex trafficking and
sex abuse case involving at least three
teenage girls who were in the church he
called the church leader sick and
demented the type of crimes that belong
nowhere in our society from human
trafficking production of child
pornography oral copulation rape
statutory rape child molestation
extortion conspiracy and more the
Attorney General said the beloved church
leader was provided by his followers
with images of teenage girls who were
told to quote take off their clothing
touch each other's breasts and vaginas
and lick whipped cream off each other's
breasts unquote
they were parishioners if you wish to
call them that this is a it's a pretty
large organization I hesitate to call it
a church mega church
and it has a lot of followers and these
are some people would probably call this
a case of brainwashing or where these
families are influenced the bale has
presently been set with regard to mr.
Garcia in the amount of 50 million
dollars that amount will remain the
church leader joaquin garcia is now
being held on a bail of 50 million
dollars and a hearing this week
prosecutors said they feared he would
flee the country if there was not such a
large veil because there is a real fear
that because he has this church with
more than a million followers that he
will raise the money and he will bail
himself out and if he bails himself out
he may try to flee to the place where he
had just come from when we captured him
at la airport back to Mexico or
somewhere else all of this comes as the
Church of the light of the world is in a
pitched battle in a small town in
Georgia called flowery branch where the
church has bought a huge tract of more
than 300 acres to create its own City
the plans include a church resort hotels
even a shopping center some other holy
suppers have drawn over a hundred
thousand participants for several days
how do you do that in a town with little
one-lane rural roads and some little
subdivisions how do you do that in a
town of eight thousand people local
residents have organized a determined
opposition to stop the church project
roll right out alive
[Music]
- oh that businessman David Nixon is
among those against it saying the church
has similarities to a cult it's more
about the leader it's more about his
glory and and you can only get through
you know to have him through this guy in
his family and I would say that they
share more in line with what people
traditionally think of as a cult
church leaders claim its opponents in
Georgia are racist and unchristian Jack
Freeman is a minister in the light of
the world Church what's happening in
Georgia is a is a war as a battle we
need to fight we are not going to lay
down and give up and allow ourselves to
be taken captive or move or run off now
with the new criminal charges against
church leader joaquin garcia local
residents in georgia say they are more
determined than ever to keep the
development out if it also turns out
that the hierarchy of the church gets
convicted of you know child rape and sex
trafficking well I think that helps make
our case even more ironclad
with their leader the apostle of Jesus
Christ behind bars awaiting trial
members of the church were instructed to
pray for joaquin garcia and his deputies
and lawyers said he was targeted because
he was a man of the cloth and promised
he would soon be proven innocent
the false allegations leveled against
her church leader apostle nasan joaquin
garcia have caused our church a deep
sadness however our church community is
confident that our the allegations will
be proven false joining us now by Skype
is Alan Sawyer a lawyer for the accused
apostle mr. Sawyer thank you very much
for being here
your client remains behind bars fifty
million dollars bail that's the largest
ever in Los Angeles County thanks for
having me Brian
yeah it's a very unusual amount of bail
and I think it's based on a false
premise that you should take into
account the assets and the wealth of a
church and determining an individual's
bail the reason why is a false premise
is because prior to this incident and
after this incident the church's
finances are completely separate for mr.
Garcia's finances he does not sign on
any bank accounts he cannot direct where
money is sent and the church has a bylaw
and a rule that says that their funds
cannot be used for criminal defense mr.
Saur let me ask you your client I take
it is going to plead not guilty he's
gonna fight this of course yeah he's
gonna enter a plea of not guilty we
expect to have a bail hearing next
Friday and we're extremely confident
that he will be allowed to have a
reasonable bail and this case will
proceed and due course and you'll be
fine not guilty mr. Soria we have a
question for you from our control room
from executive producer Rhonda Schwarz
Rhonda Allen is the church doing its own
investing
Gatien of these allegations i have
general counsel in the church and it's
very likely that they will do some kind
of internal investigation but we as a
defense are running our own
investigation it's an independent but is
there any truth to this at all mr.
Sawyer
does he know these three girls I look we
haven't been provided discovery yet in
this case which is unusual I mean the
the Attorney General did an
unprecedented press conference where he
claimed my client was an animal demented
and sick and that is completely
inappropriate for a prosecutor to do the
presumption of innocence supposed to be
present in a case and we there should be
no attempt to taint the jury pool and I
think mr. Becerra across the line
and violated ethical standards in the
press conference on the allegations way
they've been presented at this point
well Alan Sawyer thank you very much
we'll keep tabs on what's going on as
the cork goes through the process coming
up next a decorated Navy SEAL about to
go on trial for war crimes
he says he's being persecuted by the
government for doing his job when we
return
back now with a look at the upcoming
trial of Navy SEAL Andy Gallagher
accused by members of his own elite team
of war crimes killing an unarmed
teenager Isis fighter and randomly
shooting at innocent civilians including
an elderly man and a young girl Special
Warfare operator chief Eddie Gallagher
has denied the charges and says the men
in his unit alpha platoon SEAL Team 7
are lying about him the investigation of
Gallagher began after he was accused of
stabbing to death this injured teenage
Isis fighter in Iraq two years ago seen
in this Iraqi TV video shortly before
Gallagher allegedly killed him other
allegations include times when Gallagher
in various sniper posts shot and killed
random innocent civilians and then later
boasted about it
Gallagher was released from custody two
weeks ago and he and his family have
launched a campaign to defend him
outside court recently his wife Andrea
told reporters about the pain she and
the family are going through called the
kids yesterday and just let them know
the judge's ruling and you know they
just they all just burst into tears it's
a very emotional thing for us to have to
go through this level of shame and this
type of a travesty but we're hopeful
that again it'll all come out we will be
vindicated his name will be cleared and
everything will be restored that's what
we're still hoping for the campaign to
defend Gelder has received extensive
airtime on Fox News where both his wife
and his brother Shawn have appeared
Shawn what is the evidence against your
brother that was at trial nothing so
there is none now I don't I don't want
to seem like I'm glib or coming off
really quickly with that but the
allegations against Eddie are based
mainly on just words someone's word
against his the Gallagher campaign on
Fox News has apparently been well
received at the White House where
President Trump said recently he is
considering a presidential pardon for
Gallagher
and we're joined now by the lead lawyer
Freddie Gallagher Tim parla Tory mr.
Paula Terry thank you very much for
joining us are you set to go to trial on
Monday yes we are
is the evidence strong interview week
the evidence of innocence is pretty
strong the evidence that the government
intends to present I it was week before
but it seems to be getting weaker by the
day are some of these former Navy SEALs
who were with Eddie Gallagher's unit are
they going to testify against him in
court we expect that a small portion of
the platoon is going to testify on
behalf of the government other members
of the platoon we expect will testify in
manners favorable to the defense and
we're certainly not talking about a
whole platoon that's trying to turn
their teeth in we're talking about a
couple of disgruntled individuals this
has been quite a case with allegations
that the prosecution was involved in
major misconduct trying to spy on your
emails two of the prosecutors had been
removed from the case what's going on
there well those aren't allegations that
was a finding by the judge the NCIS and
the lead prosecutor Chris Chappell AK
violated the fourth fifth and sixth
amendments by putting illegal tracking
software on to emails that they send to
defense attorneys and to a member the
media so as a result the lead prosecutor
was removed one of the other prosecutors
was awarded off by the Marine Corps but
the judge did not dismiss the charges as
you had asked so that trial will go
ahead the trial will go ahead you know
this is it's a serious charge it's a
murder charge so I recognize that ask
him for dismissal was a pretty tough
hill to climb I think that he certainly
had the legal basis for it but he by
removing these prosecutors by then
releasing my client from custody
he gave us additional peremptory
challenges and he also took the maximum
penalty of life imprisonment without the
possibility of parole off the table so
we're set up in a really good position
to go into this trial but this is highly
unusual isn't it within the ranks of the
Navy SEALs such a tight group for one
group
men to testify against your client it is
unusual but I think it's something that
you're going to see be seeing more of as
we have the generational gap between
these younger seals who think that they
know better than the older more
experienced leadership and just because
they can't get what they want they feel
like they need to go in and make false
complaints so you're saying they're
lying actually I I am
I'm absolutely saying that they're lying
I'm looking forward to cross-examining
them you know these are you they're
supposed to be our nation's elite
warriors and yet I look at NCI as videos
of them crying as they're telling
stories that then when you pull out the
video of the actual event they're
clearly lying about so I can't wait to
get these guys on the stand and you're
gonna take them apart you say absolutely
absolutely we intend to annihilate the
government's case and what videos do you
refer to that you're going to show
there's plenty of videos there's videos
of immediately before and immediately
after the alleged incident there's
videos of like I said these guys crying
in an NCIS interrogation room a year
later as they're retelling this false
narrative so it's going to be
interesting to see how they can explain
that the false story that they used to
put my client in jail is so starkly
different from what the evidence shows
at the time and for the the testimony
they've given so far is that he Eddie
Gallagher boasted of killing lots of
innocent civilians the the testimony so
far the only person that's testified is
the NCIS agent Joe our Penske and he
went in there and mischaracterized in
several respects what the witnesses told
him and so none of these witnesses have
actually ever testified now one feature
within the SEAL Teams within any special
operations or combat unit is that
there's a lot of dark humor and so to a
certain extent they've taped tried to
take some of that dark humor out of
context and put it out there as if it's
backed
and quickly President Trump has talked
about a pardon any news on that that my
only source of information on that is
the news media we have not reached out
to the White House we have not in any
way asked for a pardon you know our
focus is on going into the courtroom and
winning this in the court if whatever
the president decides you know certainly
I wouldn't want to dissuade him from
that but that's not something we ever
pushed for Tim Paula Torrey thank you
very much for joining us you have some
busy weeks ahead up next our shout-out
for James Foley the journalist who was
killed by Isis and the Brooklyn artist
who is now making it his mission for the
world to finally see the work the Jim
Foley left behind the horrors of war
turned into art when we return our shout
out tonight for an unusual collaboration
between an artist in Brooklyn working to
honor a brave journalist James Foley was
40 years old when his career as a war
zone photo journalist was tragically and
brutally cut short too awful tragic news
from overseas late today it's about an
American journalist named James Foley
beheaded by members of the violent
Islamic group Isis he reported from
dangerous places bearing witness to the
lives of people a world away now almost
five years later an artist in Brooklyn
Bradley McCollum has made it his mission
to let the world finally see the work
that James Foley risk his life to create
when you searched his name all you would
find were the evidences of his execution
and it did seem to sort of Brandt
emboldened the executioner but did
little to tell his story so with the
permission of James Foley's mother Diane
but Column began to go through the video
and still photos that James had left
behind in his backpack that had never
been seen publicly and inside the
backpack for these five hard drives and
his old computer and at that point this
project became very personal
using an industrial-sized printer
McCollum first creates a silk overlay of
the images he has selected and then
places the printed fabric over a canvas
painting he is made of one of the scenes
fully captured with his camera so for me
this becomes this moment of Christmas
well the painting behind me is one of my
favorite paintings in this series and it
really combines two images it's
capturing what I really think of is the
kind of this moment of beauty within a
place of absolute destruction and kind
of ruins and overlaying this oil
painting of the landscape is a detailed
scan and reprinting of a letter that Jim
wrote another one taken in Libya during
the overthrow of the Libyan leader
Kadafi what you see in the painting is a
whole series of rebel soldiers with
their cell phone cameras taking an image
of this fallen soldier we know now that
is Qaddafi's son dozens of images photos
of war turned into art for me it's not
important that you understand the sub
narratives I think as a painting it
begins to speak universally to to war
and conflict and accountability before
being taken hostage by Isis Foley had
earlier been held hostage by a group in
Libya which ultimately let him go but
not before putting him through a true
test of his courage I jumped up tried to
say we were journalists then I was hit
several times with blood of ak-47
punched and dragged into a vehicle with
my hands tied behind my back
for Bradley McCollum there is a heavy
responsibility to get it right and it is
a responsibility it's a responsibility
to to create work that both honors and
and takes the next step beyond simply
being a memorial but one that transforms
and makes us think in a much broader
sense so it is a tribute to his
journalism oh absolutely
yeah absolutely none of these paintings
would exist if Jim wasn't as committed
to telling the stories he told I'm not
using anyone elses images I'm looking at
and thinking about and making selections
based on the footage he took in a way it
feels often like I'm collaborating with
Jim and so our shout out tonight -
Bradley McCallum whose works of art
bring new life to the heroic journalism
of James Foley that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here next week